bonsoir massimo nava merci d'être avec
nous sur rt france donc 59,3 % des
votants se sont prononcés ce soir en
faveur d'un soutien au gouvernement
draghi est ce que cela vous étonne les
mouvements 5 étoiles peut-il sortir
affaibli de ce choix et mathieu renzi en
ressort au contraire grandit pas écouter
sous les futurs des matières in si c'est
vraiment très très difficile à vivre
parce que c'est un jeu de poker est pour
le moment est réussie parce que c'est
lui a fait qu'il ya un peu ouvert la rue
pour le nouvel gouvernement avec mario
ce qui concerne les 5 étoiles
il ya un peu des ders décision parce
qu'elle fait les mouvements ses traits
déchiré et la majorité c'est très faible
et parce qu'elle soit 100% des votantes
pour un mouvement où la participation
était de presque 70 mille votants tu
sais pas c'est pas ces problématiques
d'ordre d'un moment très unis évidemment
de bêtes et grill ok après l'ont
longuement des silences a décidé dé
reprendre un peu la main d'oeuvre de
mohmand a choisi évidemment monnaie à
changer un peu la donne mais il ya rien
d des tensions à l'intérieur très fort
parce que vous savez mouvement cette
étoile est née contre la classe
dirigeante contre les banques contre
même la personnalité des mario draghi se
changeait tout c'est franchement très
difficile mais en ce moment on assiste à
un vrai dramatique je vous avais dit
machiavélique ferrari aux italiens
typiquement italienne mais avec un
résultat pour le moment spectaculaire
c'est à dire la personnalité plus
important plus estimé plus considérés
dans la dans les world à l'italie est le
même au niveau international aujourd'hui
c'est l'échelle et prochaine pour un
chef
gouvernement intervienne et quand la gym
majorité qui comprendra aussi la gauche
partie de la droite et les mouvements 5
étoiles est un plus est sorti un peu un
miracle je dirais un miracle si d'état
mardi le leader de la ligue 1 au bar
c'est à dire la droite nationaliste un
peu un peu anti européenne qui a choisi
de participer à cette gouvernement et
donc c'est vrai qu'étant tous les effets
de la parole ni délai dès l'émergence
économique les problèmes qu'il était lié
aussi le pays d'europe qui a vraiment
changé la donne et forcé tous les partis
politiques à mettre à côté les intérêts
personnels
elle est créée c'est la politique
politicienne pour à tora un projet que
plus que d'une plus longue et et d'un
ampleur importante en plus quand on
contourne mancelle l italie c'est les
pays qui ont plus profité des erreurs
comme un enfant c'est à dire puisque est
de 120 milliards d'euros qui sont prêts
à d'arrivée avant d'être versés à
l'italie sous forme est subventionné des
prêtres et évidemment il faut avoir des
projets très concrètes pour bien un
dépenser cet argent qui est évidemment
dans les mains des mario draghi tout le
monde se sente beaucoup plus sûr alors
mario draghi c'est l'homme de la bce
c'est bhl a connu pour être un
technocrate est ce que c'est la victoire
ce soir d'un retour des est libre retour
de la technocratie en italie non parce
que à mon avis c'est le personnage c'est
beaucoup différent de mario monti si
vous pensez à l'est
les précédentes disons gouvernement
technocratique d'abord parce que mario
draghi s'est aussi je voudrais pas qu'un
politicien aide mais il ya des roms à
lang expérience à la banque italienne a
le bac c'est un rite aliens et surtout à
la banque et européennes a amèné
vraiment au congrès politique et
monétaire et social et tout le monde
connaît qui avait des relations très
stricte avec un gala mère qu'elle donc
je pense que on peut pas considérer
simplement mario draghi comme un autre
fonctionnaire politicien c'est
l'association pour vous pourquoi
remontée justement redresser la
situation s'est vraiment l'homme de la
situation
absolument parce qu'un puce dabola les
soutiennent des forces politiques comme
je disais d'ailleurs mais aussi il y va
aussi à former un gouvernement qui ya là
des techniciennes des personnalités des
séquences de sa confiance mais aussi des
politiques des hommes politiques qui
représente un tel tous les panoramas et
politique il a déjà annoncé un chose à
mon avis très important c'est à dire un
grain de ministères pour la transition
écologique un peu sous le modèle
français qui avait fait sarkozy après et
aussi hollande à l'époque
et tant qu un grand ministère kiki qui
comprend différents fonctionne
l'infrastructure l'écologie la
transition énergétique tout ça et ça
s'imprime y ait un premier résultat est
bon on verra après la formation l'équipe
que cela a lancé je pensais de membres
près de marque du tap et donc en plus ça
saoule souligne ainsi que mario draghi a
fait tomber les spreads déjà les bijoux
qui était qui en proposait louis au
gouvernement est presque un milliard
d'euros d'intérêts que l'italie a
est il pour simplement avec l'annoncé
des sonos et donc c'est tout le monde
est content de ça et dans les sondages
un pis c'est vraiment transversale à
tous les phases politique
la satisfaction ne pourra pour sa
nomination
on imagine qu'à une urgence comme dans
tous les pays quasiment du monde
malheureusement la crise sanitaire
peut-être et la campagne de vaccination
est ce qu'on fait confiance or
l'expertisé de mario draghi
sur ce point patrick alors c'est vous
savez sur la campagne de vaccination n'a
fait les gouvernements précédents d'un
de ses co qui a bien travaillé et
l'italie avaient beaucoup plus des
fascinations que la france pourrait par
exemple est un fait il ya un peu des
défiance entre les 10 heures en régions
et en des propositions de mario draghi à
ce moment des rendrait la haine envers
la coordination des la distribution de
vaccins au niveau puissante alizés pas
ce qu'est un pl est un plus vous serez
réel
l'italienne bailly rester fédéral avec
beaucoup d des pouvoirs locales
régionales aussi et donc il ya toujours
des comptes suisses ou entre les régions
des ris de veau lancé et ça je pense que
mario draghi la terminer cette mettre
fin à cette contrainte à tous ces
polémiques sont sortis et qui ont enfin
pu endommager beaucoup la la la
situation n'en crée des problèmes qui
pouvaient être est beaucoup plus facile
à résoudre avec un vision centralisée de
dbd l'émergent sanitaires merci massimo
nava je rappelle que cet éditorialiste
avoir été avec nous en direct sur rt
france